any time anywhere and without
preconditions that's
washington's latest offer to pyongyang
on opening a dialogue over its nuclear
program
the biden administration's new envoy for
north korea was in seoul on monday to
push forward efforts to restart the
stalled diplomacy
the u.s south korea and japan are
looking for ways to convince pyongyang
to stop developing nuclear weapons and
ballistic missiles
washington has promised a quote
calibrated practical approach
and last week leader kim jong-un gave
his first reaction to that policy
he ordered his officials to prepare for
both dialogue
and confrontation with the emphasis on
the latter
here's the us envoy we will earlier
today
for either cause you know we are still
waiting to hear back from
our proposal for a meeting and hopefully
chairman king's reference to dialogue
indicates that we will get a positive
response
soon joining us is jay wu shin an
analyst with the open nuclear network
it seems as if the two sides aren't
really on the same page
at all if the u.s is talking about
dialogue and north korea seems more
focused on potential conflict
that's right the united states and
its counterparts in south korea and
tokyo is obviously focusing
on the dialogue part of the expression
that
received much attention last week where
kim jong-un is reported to have said
that the country should prepare for both
dialogue and confrontation
the expression from last week in itself
is not particularly new i would say
the the reason why it got a lot of
attention is that it's the first time
that
kim jong-un himself has signaled
to the united states
that that would be prepared for for
dialogue or confrontation
following the new administration
um but we have we have heard similar
things from north korea before
in fact yes
well i'm wondering how much is
pyongyang's lack of interest or
eagerness
lack of eagerness related to kim jong-un
already having had photo ops with
america already
formerly with uh president trump in
singapore and vietnam and also at the
dmz so there's no sense of urgency
that's right i think that's exactly what
north korea is thinking at the moment
in fact in may 18 this year
we have seen a statement from north
korea's first vice foreign minister
chisonhi
in which she said exactly that north
korea wouldn't be giving away
opportunities like singapore and hanoi
anymore
unless there's a change in u.s policy
and so far it appears that what north
korea has seen so far is not
not sufficient for north korea to really
come out and to respond to
the americans efforts to engage in
dialogue
now we've reported on covet in north
korea and the country has become
even more insular during the pandemic
it seems to be in a very bad place
economically with even some people
mentioning
of a return to the hardships of the
famine decade of the 1990s
how much is this a factor in driving
pyongyang's foreign policy
we first of all we do not believe it to
be as bad as
in the 90s but certainly it's a very
serious situation
in fact during last week's meeting
explainary meetings in north korea
kim jong-un is reported to have put a
lot of focus on the dire food situation
so
that's domestically where the focus lies
by the
government and um it's it's indeed a
factor that could play a role in
its foreign foreign relations uh there
has not been
any any major engagement
with uh basically any country in person
for for quite some time now and that's
this is clearly due to
the covet 19 situation jay wushan
thank you so much for joining us
thank you